do you need grammar to speak well the
quick answer is no in my opinion I tend
to agree with Steven crash that grammar
can be a hindrance it can be a help it
can uh explain things to us it can
explain things that we have already
experienced in the language it can show
us examples of different patterns that
we can then use however if we try to
remember the grammar if we try to second
guess ourselves then grammar becomes
what Steven crashing calls the effective
filter it's something that
emotionally we start to doubt whether
what we would normally retrieve as easy
to use or patterns that we're
comfortable using and we do it on the
Fly while we're speaking and now we
start to say well is this correct and we
want to pass it through this filter of
grammar is this correct and basically
that inhibits us in our speaking it's
like the proverbial centipede you know
100 fet if it has to think about which
foot to put forward the left foot or the
right foot pretty soon the centipede
can't walk so grammar has its role some
people actually like grammar so that's
fine but if the goal is to speak well
some people think you need to focus on
grammar in order to speak well I don't
think so it gets back to the example of
the chess player someone who knows the
rules is no match for someone who has
vast experience playing chess so the
question then is first of all what is
meant by speaking what do we what
happens when we speak before getting
into the question of what speaking well
means let's just consider what speaking
entails speaking entails as I mentioned
in my last video speaking entails
planning we actually have to plan the
utterance what we're going to say and
planning it draws on our memory it
planning and memory comes from the same
part of our brain and when we speak
apparently We Begin by grabbing easy to
use words or structures that we're very
comfortable with this is if we're
speaking in a foreign language I presume
maybe in our own languages we use those
things that we're comfortable starting
with that gives us time to plan the next
thing we're going to say and we also
reuse structures that we're comfortable
using that have worked for us before so
there are three elements one is easy to
use items the second is planned reuse
but the third one is suppressing things
that don't fit so that can can be words
that sound similar but they're not
appropriate words that have a similar
meaning but are not exactly what we want
in this context or it could be patterns
from our own language so I noticed that
Swedish people typically will say it is
many trees in the forest instead of
there are because that's the pattern in
Swedish German people will say I have
been living in the United States since
many years but in fact it's for many
years because in German that's the
pattern so when we're speaking we need
to pull from our memory words that we
are very comfortable using the easy to
use things to get started we then reuse
structures that worked before but we
suppress words or patterns that don't
work and that apparently when they
measure what happens in the brain that's
what we do so obviously we need a vast
repertoire we need a lot of memory
experience words patterns that work in
the language so that's when we speak
what do we mean by speaking well at link
I used to tutor English 15 years ago and
at that time we kept statistics we had
sort of types of errors that people made
because at that time I thought it would
be useful to point out to a learner you
had X perent was singular plural X
perent was wrong tense X perent was
something else and for each language we
had these categories well overwhelmingly
and I even did correct some people in
French overwhelmingly the biggest
problem was incorrect word usage in
other words it wasn't so much that it
was grammatical mistakes it was that the
words they used together are words that
normally in English we wouldn't use
together and after all when we say speak
well we're not talking about some
theoretical logical way that the
language should be used many of those
sort of structures in other languages
that interfere with us when we're
speaking a new language they're
logically fine in their language double
negatives or it is many trees in the
forest it's fine logically but that's
just not how the language is used so the
most common type of error is using words
that don't belong together there is a
term collocation which talks about words
that are normally found together there's
so many potential collocations I don't
think it's worthwhile studying a list of
collocations it's a matter more of being
exposed to so much of the language that
you naturally feel that certain words
belong together another aspect of
speaking well and as I say I'm going to
leave pronunciation out of the equation
I might do a separate video on
pronunciation I think you can speak the
language very well and have an obvious
accent the two issues are different but
if we say speaking well what do we mean
by speaking well we mean using words
with Precision so if we talk about
language
acquisition and we have the verb acquire
now there are many similar words I mean
there is the word get which is a very
general and therefore not very precise
word there is the word obtain but we
obtain satisfaction we acquire a
language we get fed up in other words
there are so many examples of how the
accurate way to use a given word and one
that is natural because our goal is to
be natural in the language now what is
natural in Quebec may not be natural in
France and so far as French is concerned
what is natural in Scotland may not be
natural in Australia but there is a
natural form of the language that is
valuable to us because those are the
people we want to communicate with and
in order to become a good speaker and
therefore to speak naturally and to
speak well you have to have a large
vocabulary you have to be able to use
words precisely and you have to be able
to use words that naturally Belong
Together and even if you create a
sentence which is logical grammatically
but the wrong words are used I don't
consider that speaking well so the
grammar these rules and reading up on
the rules there's nothing wrong with
doing that it's possible that if you
read a grammar book and I would
recommend reading a grammar book in the
target language and if this grammar book
has lots of examples that can help
provide you with this inventory of
phrasing that you can draw on when
you're planning your utterance But
ultimately you have to develop a natural
reflex so that when you go through this
process of planning your utterance that
you have a natural ability to bring out
easy to use words structures at work and
you suppress those things that don't
work so you won't be surprised to hear
that I think that input is the key to
speaking well but input and output are
intricately
connected so just as when we speak we're
drawing from our memory and we're
planning what to say and we're trying to
anticipate what we're going to use when
we are listening or reading we are also
active we are also anticipating what's
going to come at us that has been proven
in in the studies they do the Erp
studies of the brain and so forth so the
two activities are interrelated but it
still boils down to spending enough time
reading and listening that you develop
this ability to produce the language and
reading and listening are a little
different first of all when you are
speaking of course you are practicing
speaking of course you are listening to
what the other person has to say and of
course that's a valuable thing to do and
as you develop a stronger and stronger
base in the language you want to speak
as much as you can as often as you can
without worrying about how you do
because you will gradually improve if
you keep speaking however when it comes
to the input activity reading and
listening are a little different
listening and especially if you're
listening to something that grabs you
like an audio book a story that creates
sort of an emotional connection to the
language can also happen in reading but
reading is a little bit different
there's the sound of the language again
as we grow older the different parts of
our brain apparently become more and
more interconnected the uh myelin coding
speeds up the connections with with
different parts of the brain and so your
emotions your empathy your feelings all
of these become more closely connected
with the sort of purely you know
thinking or reasoning part of your brain
and so when we are learning a language
and we want to acquire these words then
it's important that we connect
emotionally uh with what we're listening
to and reading that's why it's so
important to choose things of interest
to you to listen to or read it's also
true apparently that when we are reading
in our brain it's as if we were speaking
to ourselves so reading is also a form
of output a form of speaking so that's
just to say that all of these activities
are interconnected so even if you don't
have the opportunity to speak the
language where you're living getting
engaged with input activities can help
you know improve your ability to speak
and it is certainly true that in our own
languages the people who speak the best
are the people who have read the most
widely so reading is very important in
order to improve your ability eventually
to speak now some of you may say yeah
but I how can I listen when I don't
understand anything how can I read when
I have so few words so obviously you
have to gradually build up your ability
to read I think the goal should be to
read a paper book again there's some
research that suggest that we learn
better from paper books than from
digital material tablets or or computer
screens but you can't get to a paperbook
until you have a sufficient vocabulary
and of course that's why we developed
you're not surprised again to hear me
say but that's why I developed link
because I had these books at home in
Spanish and German full of words that I
didn't understand and so I couldn't
enjoy reading them but I wanted to get
to where I can enjoy reading a paper
book and that's why at link we can start
with many stories you can go through
material in sentence view there's so
many different ways that you can
gradually build up in a somewhat
intensive way your ability to eventually
read extensively and if you can
eventually read novels and serious books
or books on subject of interest to you
extensively by paper always have a book
with you and you read widely in the
language that you're learning you will
become a good speaker of that language
and you won't need to remember or try to
remember rules of grammar in order to
speak well because you will automatic Al
as you retrieve the words you want to
use and the structures you want to use
and you suppress structures that you
don't want or the words that you don't
want to use you're going to become a
better and better speaker of the
language